movies were foreign to us like my dad uh
I think he took me to one movie in my my
whole life like my the first movie he
took me to was uh he wanted it was funny
it was Indiana Jones came out I think I
was like 10 and he was like oh don't
check his movie Indiana Jones and I
didn't know what it was because it said
Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom but
it sounded like Raiders a lost Arc it
was lost AR right and it's I thought it
was like a movie about the Bible about
you know because it was like the Arc of
the ping in and I was like I don't want
to see this a religious movie so I cried
and was like I want to see Annie so my
dad took me to see Annie and he fell
asleep and I watched Little Orphan Annie
and that was like the first movie I ever
watched it was like 10 because I didn't
go to the movies you know yeah um so so
telling them I want to be an actor was
like uh tell him I want to go to Mars it
was just like not a thing that was
possible so they laughed and I didn't
want to be laughed at so next time they
said what do you want to be I said a
lawyer and they were like oo a lawyer in
the family family my son's going to be a
lawyer you know uh so so then I kind of
convinced myself that's what I would be
you know and uh I went to to all through
high school and didn't do a play in high
school ever uh and then I went to
college and I and I went to one year uh
at St John's University and I studied
pre-law you know uh and and then I I I
took like an acting 101 class and I
really liked it I was like Wow because I
was so shocked gu it was freeing for me
cuz when I was playing other characters
like people don't see me they see these
other I could do anything as a as a
character right uh it's always that
acting
101 and uh and so then I met this guy
and he was like a
manager and I and I was trying to get
into like modeling a little bit and uh I
was doing like little things here and
there it wasn't like you know just to
for to pick up money on the side and
then and then he said if you want to be
an actor you should really study it and
so he helped me transfer into NYU to
study theater there and so I told my
parents hey I'm going Tove I'm going to
transfer it to NYU and I actually
auditioned and I got in to the theater
program there and they they said why are
you studying acting I don't understand
and this school's like twice as much as
your other school yeah I said Well it
has a you know as a as a as a lawyer you
have to stand up in front of people I'm
really shy and acting is required to be
a lawyer lying yeah I totally Li totally
playing I see what you're doing so I
said you know you have to stand up in
front of people and it's like doing a PL
you have to take acting class that'll
help me be a better lawyer and they
didn't know so the the good thing about
my parents was there's there's parents
that like if their kid like shits in a
box they're like look what my kid made
you know and my and then there's the
other parents that are just like uh on
the other side like my parents like my
mom never came to a baseball game you
know my dad took me to like one movie my
whole life like they just did their
thing and I did my thing and in some
ways like it was good because they kind
of stayed out of like I I I actually had
a conversation with my mom the other day
I said because I had a motorcycle at 19
I was like did you guys like me like I
would never let my my son did you like
me get a motorcycle at 19 she was like
oh no that's what you wanted to do I I
mean I thought you were crazy but I was
like you know that's what it was like
they just didn't they were they let me
be me which was really kind of wonderful
but they loved you and they gave you all
that stuff and they loved me and and it
wasn't like see that's why it worked
they gave you the everything it wasn't
like they were ignoring and abandoning
me they just weren't on top of you they
just weren't on top of me they weren't
helicopter parents so like when I said I
was going into NYU they were just like
okay you know I got a baseball game this
weekend okay you like I'm coming home
tonight I'm going out okay you come
don't come home late okay you know like
they didn't jeez I wish that was my they
didn't really helicopter paring me get
your ass home the [__] out of you so so
they were loose in that sense but in the
sense of like hey I really think you
could make it as an actor they weren't
that either but they never said you
can't make it as an they just were like
he's going NYU he's taking act I don't
know you know they just so then so I
took I went to NYU and I studied acting
and then and then I ended up getting um
an episode like a guest starring episode
or something and I was like hey I'm
going to be on this guest and I had like
the lead G uh like guest um you know
episode lead what are they call lead
lead guest lead you know the lead is
that what they call guest leads guest
lead I don't know the lead actor and the
guest guest leap Opera it was a I can't
say the show but it was a it was a show
that dealt with uh law and it also dealt
with other stuff like or order like like
order and and there was also like
criminal and criminal stuff and and
judge stuff Goa got and stuff like and
so um so I did a show that was my first
an due to the sax strike Peter fanelli
can't say the word beep beep yeah so uh
it dealt with like judges and and law so
I ended up being the lead a guest leader
on that show and and I said I'm going to
be on this series and so my parents
watching and they thought I was going to
be like the guy just kind of like oh
that's my hand you see it you know the
guy just walked through the door in the
back Blown Away no they weren't they
were they were surprised but I never got
the I actually never got the oh my God
that was amazing I can't believe you did
did that either they were just but they
weren't like I think they were just a
little like great you got paid that's
they were just like oh that's cool and
they really didn't think anything of I
mean
honestly for the first 20 years of my
career my dad would be like listen if
you uh if you ever need it your room but
we still have a room for you like like
so I never got always got the same thing
I never got the uh you know I think you
finally made it you know I feel like
they're proud of me but after you did a
movie with a bunch of
vampires no I think that they come on no
cuz here's the thing my they don't
understand the world of it so when I go
home you know my moms were interested in
like why aren't you eating you know I
mean eat your pasta like you're getting
too skinny eat this like so it's like
the the blessing of my parents are they
would love me no matter what I did you
know what I mean the fact that they they
only care don't make me cry now they
only care if I'm happy that like my mom
says like if if if something's really
successful she are you happy then I'm
happy too she doesn't care if it's
successful as long as I'm
happy they're happy which is really did
they ask you that did they ask you they
ask they are you happy are you good yeah
like I'll be like hey I got this movie G
are good are you happy yeah like good
you